okay good morning everybody uh glad to
see you all here
we're not going to be addressing House
Bill 655 as such we're going to go
through
the oplc's press release
as a team which is a teaser of things
that are alleged that are included in
House Bill 2 which is not yet out
the finance committee has said that Edna
if Edna takes a position on any of these
parts they'll follow it so
what I'd like to do today is identify
which parts we need more information on
which parts we can leave alone and which
parts we've covered elsewhere
so
um triage essentially
and we'll end up with a long list of
questions and action items
I presume so uh since we have a couple
of people here to talk about the Wetland
scientist
license which is being
which is number 34 on the list of
licenses to be eliminated I'd like to
have them
tell us what the problem would be if
their license would be eliminated
gentlemen if you could
see
I'll start out by saying that I know
that like
um Professional Engineers the
certification and the
continuing continuing education is
primarily through a third party
Professional Organization so the
question is if you eliminate the state
license
what comp what problems would that cause
you so please introduce yourself
okay first thing is you got to turn on
the mic
the Mike silver thing push the silver
pull it towards you so it's easier
so we got a red lights out we're looking
for a red
we got it
okay great
um Madam chair members of the committee
my name is Jay Obi I am a certified well
with scientist and I'm here on on behalf
of nanners the New Hampshire Association
of natural resource scientists
and good morning my name is Collis Adams
hi please I've got to speak more
directly okay yes we are we are live on
on YouTube good morning uh and thank you
for having us my name is Collis Adams
the first name is spelled
c-o-l-l-i-s last name is conventional
spelling of Adams Ada m s I am a
certified Wetland scientist in the state
of New Hampshire I am also the president
of the New Hampshire Association of
natural resource scientists or as it's
affected affectionately known nanners
and my wife reminds me of that every
time I go to a meeting
um anyways we're here to help and assist
you in answering any questions and
provide clarification as we may be able
to we have prepared a letter for you and
I'm not going to read the letter thank
you you're welcome I know how that can
go but I will paraphrase from it just to
hit the highlights we don't need to know
how wonderful Wetland scientists are
we're going to take that as granted
thank you very much appreciate that we
believe we serve a very valuable role
and function in the state
um but I do want to just talk uh in sort
of general terms and then get into some
specifics there are over 300 certified
folks in New Hampshire and that's a
pretty significant number we provide
some valuable services
to a lot of different folks from
development interests we're assuming
that to the municipalities and I will
speak to that because I am also on my
local Board of Select select board as
well as my local planning board and
Conservation Commission so I could speak
to the land use boards personally
um through my experience with those
boards in my hometown
um which is what Goffstown
no seriously I mean we've got 34 of
these professions and we're not going to
say any of them is not necessary yeah
what we're going to say is we're trying
to decide is is a state license
necessary yes and assuming you've got
all the certification and training and
other wonderfulness
Madam chair I think I can take a moment
to get to the Crux of what you're
looking for here in in that you know
what happens if the certification goes
away essentially no not the
certification or the license the license
the license
so I think it's important to recognize
that the that the
certified Welton scientist in the in the
soil scientists in the state of New
Hampshire play very important role as it
relates to economy in New Hampshire that
is that is we act as the liaison between
the developers and government officials
I I don't please what I'm trying to get
at is we do not want to say there will
not be Wetland scientists we don't want
to say there won't be certified Wetland
scientists what we want to say is after
you've got this your certification right
now you have to apply for state license
what does that license give you that the
certification does not that's what I'm
looking for
the license gives us the professional
the the expertise in providing the in
analyzing Wetlands looking at the
functions and values of wetlands and in
assisting with determining the boundary
between what areas are developable and
what what areas are not that's what your
certification your training and
experience
gives you what does the state license
give you
the state license gives us the
credentials to to demonstrate that we
have that knowledge and expertise to to
perform that analysis that's the only
thing they give you
because we do it we do a number of
things
we
I'm not getting through to you all right
so so here's the deal
um
you know
you'd have the training you have the
certification
other than paying a fee I haven't looked
at it in detail but one of the main
requirements to actually get the license
is that you have the certification
so having the certification
demonstrates that you know you've done
whatever that certification organization
needs and probably most of what the
licensing would require you you are a
certified Wetland scientist the question
is what in a very practical sense would
you be unable to do if the license went
away but you still had certification
it's a very specific issue
well
we would hope the short answer to that
is we would hope nothing
well that's excellent that says that the
I'm glad to hear that that's as brief as
I can be no well that's that's exactly
right the uh in some cases that's what
it is yeah we would hope that if it was
converted from a certification to a
license the same standards would be in
effect and the individuals would still
be able to continue doing their work
exactly that's uh that's exactly right
we the license is something that when
you have your certification from your
your Professional Organization
you apply for the license and pay the
fee and then you get the state state
license
and in many cases that I noticed your
letter says there's very few complaints
the having the license doesn't Grant you
a great deal
of Authority or in or respect than your
certification does
representative please thank you
so in in in with some of the professions
uh the license
what the license does it says that you
can legally do that in this state
if you don't have the it's like driving
a car
there are all kinds of 15 year olds who
probably can drive their their family
car
um and maybe better than either one of
their parents can but the bottom line is
without the license they cannot legally
go out on the street the state roads
public roads and do it legally
uh and some professions are like that
too if you don't have the license no
matter how good you are how qualified
you are you cannot legally do it that's
correct okay so the and one of the
things that's being
considered is whether taking the license
away
harms you in any way along the lines of
what I was just talking about the
certification already says you can do it
but a license can be suspended or
revoked if you misbehave or if you're
ethically challenged or you do something
wrong or whatever you understand a
license is something that allows you to
legally operate take it away and you're
in trouble
on practicing without a license because
the certification is enough to show that
you're qualified
that's that's difficult to to
just just to speak to on the fly but
what what I can say certainly is that
with that
but I think that license you know
commits you
to adhering to that strong code of
ethics that that you're taught through
that certification process
okay
um it's today it's
it's required by
by
Des Wetlands Bureau administrative rule
it's also required by
um countless
municipalities around the state to have
a certified Wetland scientist stamp
plans much like a professional engineer
does ah so you have an official stamp
who gives you that
that is issued by the
oplc okay
and I and I know that's true for
engineers and land surveyors and and and
Landscape Architects and so forth they
need in some jobs the customer Demands a
stamp
removing that license which is
associated with that stamp would be
problematic on a large scale level
because
so many municipalities are are tied to
that
um
every every municipality that I know of
in the Seacoast area requires plans to
be submitted with us by a by a certified
Wetland scientist
no problem with that whether it's a
licensed Wetland scientist that's the
distinction
all right that was a question that I had
for uh
Doug
I have for the oplc
what is the plan for providing stamps
for those who need it
and I would if you don't know the answer
we'll leave we'll just assign it as an
action item
okay yes thank you very much gentlemen I
think
the issue is that if you if you're
calling yourself a certified Wetland
scientist that's not a problem but if
you if the
if they call for a licensed Wetland
scientist then we have to address that
issue and I think the stamp issue is
something that we need to address not
only for you but for the other
professions that generally provide one
the technical professions just
representative Schmidt I think has a
question thank you madam chair so one of
the one of the other aspects that we
want you to consider uh
um is in some instances some professions
if they don't have a license
insurance won't pay for their services
okay now that may not be the case with
you but certainly in the medical field
in some cases
without the license insurance won't pay
so I don't think that's the case for the
technical I I don't think so either but
but these are I I I I'm very supportive
of the current situation but but we're
trying to think Anew because some of the
some of these aspects are we have a
structure which is
which is seen in some quarters anyway as
burdensome and restrictive and so forth
and so on in ways that don't really make
sense it's just traditional in some
other cases uh it is legal as I talked
to before so we're that's one of the
challenges is what is absolutely needed
and what is just traditional or
conventional that might be done away
with without any harm the customers or
the purveyors
cells we we certainly recognize there's
there is
the opportunity for change in in
streamlining processes Etc and we're
certainly not not opposed to that okay
but just just we want to reiterate and
make everybody recognize
how critical the role the certified
Wetland scientist is today in terms of
assisting state government local
municipalities and federal governments
with the expertise the boots on the
ground knowledge to assist and
facilitate the permitting process
removing a certified Wetland science
would completely slow down that price I
don't believe anybody wants to remove
certified Wetland scientists from the
state's economy and the structure of how
we process things we need your expertise
the question is
does paying a fee to the state increase
the value and that's
and if it all it does is buy you a stamp
I'm not sure
sure that it does increase your value
so we're going to find out what's going
to happen with the stamps because if
your customers are relying on the stamps
as confirmation that you are a certified
Wetland scientist then we need to to
be able to comply with that
I would just reiterate too that the the
stamp
isn't we're not just purchasing a stamp
to stamp really essentially is
certifying that we have the knowledge
and the Technical Training the expertise
to be making those decisions
right there's no question about that
okay it's the we know what it means and
then I know you can't go you probably
you probably could
you can't you shouldn't be able to buy
them online because it's just randomly
you you have to show that you've got the
experience and so I'm going I'm going to
ask the oplc how they're going to deal
with that issue
in representative Lucas
yep so uh I think we understand the
stamp issue and I mean part of what
we're trying to do here is find out
things like that that might be an issue
is there anything else
any other problem other than the stamp
issue that would be cause to certify
Wetland scientists
um if the licensing went away that you
can think of
and and to your point about you know the
value and all that I I think the
certification is what shows that you've
had the training and the competence the
not the license
so there's nobody's challenging that
aspect of it but there may be practice
or legal things where uh not being
licensed might cause a problem the
stamps won and that can be dealt with
but what else if there is any
Karen if I could if you correct me if
I'm wrong I think I heard and correct me
if I'm if I'm not if I'm mistaken that
the issue with the license is you can
field complaints and revoke a license
based upon that process is that am I did
I hear that correct from this corner yes
that is one of the features of a license
but like your letter says Wetland
scientists have not proven to be a
discipline issue in this state at least
they're generally
knowledgeable and well-behaved and
ethical so follow-up and we would
certainly agree with that and reinforce
that by saying we have very very few
complaints
that we could probably count them on one
hand so if there needs to be a process
then we can probably get on board with
that if it's if it's framed properly and
it doesn't remove
our ability to provide the the important
services that we provide for landowners
municipalities and all of the other
stakeholders that are out there so I
think there's a way that we can get to
the licensing issue and the ability
based upon complaints that would come in
to be able to revoke a license and I
think and again correct me from Ryan I
think I hear that as a very important
issue it is and and some some of the the
number of complaints per licensee varies
tremendously
look Wetland scientists get very few
accountants get very few midwives get a
lot
yeah understood uh
both the certified Wetland scientist
program and nanners have a very strong
code of ethics and it speaks to those
very issues if you're not conducting
yourself in an ethical manner there are
ways that we can deal with that okay
excellent representative yeah my
follow-up actually was going to ask
about that if the certification
organization process had
some way of dealing with alleged
misbehavior and if it seems Justified
revoking the certification or something
else
where's your question again I'm sorry so
um you're certified through some
certification organization
and I think I kind of hardly got an
answer the question is does that
organization have some way of dealing
with a situation where a certified
Wetland scientist is alleged to have
misbehaved in some manner looking at it
and then potentially revoking the
certification or make some other
requirement yes through through the
natural border through the board of
natural scientists there there is a
there is a mechanism within their rule
structure other than the board of
natural scientists does your nanners
having to have that right not not the
state nothing to do with the state of
New Hampshire just the private
organization
yeah
yeah understood and again we have a very
strong code of ethics that's written
into our bylaws and every year we put on
training and we just had our annual
training and we have a session in our
annual training that is specific to
ethics
we have lawyers come in speak to us go
through different scenarios on how we
should you know handle ourselves
ethically both within the confines of
our bylaws as well as other state laws
and any other ethical requirements so
there's absolutely
mechanisms for if you will calling
people out onto the carpet and saying by
the way
you're conducting yourself what we deem
to be unethically and we have options to
take take actions to correct that does
that help yes very much so
representative Wilhelm thanks Madam
chair thanks for taking my question so I
just want to better understand aside
from certification
is there any other experience or
expertise
required in order for licensure
yes there's there's a
there is a a significant amount of
coursework that is required
um
through that's required for the
certification correct you know so
outside of that certification beyond
beyond the certificate beyond the
certification you're required to have a
two years of experience uh coursework
um in soils and the Natural Sciences
biology there are a number of qualifiers
the process for becoming certif
certified
um
isn't as is cumbersome as some might
might say and it's certainly not a
um an impediment to
entry into the workforce
um I can say I work for a private
consulting firm uh in Portsmouth and we
recently
um
put an ad out for a new a position entry
level position we we received 15 resumes
uh 75 percent of the those new
candidates straight out of Plymouth
State and UNH all had the the the core
coursework to become a certified Wetland
scientist they lacked the two years of
experience but um they certainly have a
lot of potential and like I said we've
we've just hired two two new staff
members this week
follow up Madam chair follow-up please
um so
is is the two years of experience is
that required for certification or just
for licensure in the state of New
Hampshire
certification and and to receive that
license
do you need that you need two years of
experience yes but in order to be
certified
you don't need the two years experience
they're I'm still I'm I apologize I'm
still struggling with it with
certification versus the licensure I
still I look at them as as one of the
same as a certified well and scientists
um
um is is a license and and it shows that
you that you are certified you're
certified to have your certifies and
demonstrates that you have the science
the background the expertise to to
determine and draw the line between
Uplands and wetlands those those lands
that are developable and those that are
those that are not as well as assess
those wetlands
um to assist in in determining their
true function their true functions and
values to assist with the permitting
process
yes representative black as yeah maybe I
can make an attempt at uh I mean we're
concerned about that distinction and so
the they are different so the
certification is um what this private
organization provides after you've met
whatever their requirements are and that
has nothing to do with the state of New
Hampshire
licensing is something the state of New
Hampshire does
and it has a set of requirements that
that Beyond certification that you have
to do and I think what we're trying to
understand is
um
one
what requirements does it take to get
the license Beyond certification
I assume there's a fee representative
the the statute is talking about
certification rather than licensing
which is probably part of the confusion
yes however it says that the
um
that someone
right
I think basically it says that if you
meet the requirements
you'll get a
a a license
and their specific and I the specific
requirements for certification are
listed in the statute and I believe that
the
okay any person who's passed the
examination or otherwise qualified as a
certified Wetland scientist shall upon
payment of fee be issued a certificate
okay the problem is here that the terms
are used synonymously yes that is the
problem and I and I apologize if no no
that's confused either yeah that is the
problem and so that is part of the
problem there are two of the same and
you go through the certification process
you you become certified
and and at that same time you receive
the license as well right
um
I believe that it doesn't look like
there is any requirement other than
paying the fee of course
that differentiates the license from the
certificate
at least I can't find any in the statute
there is uh
I think again that they're the same the
license in the in the certificate are
issued simultaneously
um
thank you that's the license
demonstrates that you've completed the
coursework and the training
and the tests provided by the by the
board to demonstrate that that you are
competent and you have that knowledge if
I could do a follow-up I'm still a
little please
maybe we should use the term uh private
certification state certification if the
state's using the term certification to
differentiate it but
so
to get the private certification
do you have to complete the coursework
and all of that
okay yes all right so yes you do what
the chair said read
my understanding is that you have to to
get the state certification or license
whatever you want to call it you you
first have to get the private
certification so they're not one in the
same is that incorrect that's incorrect
there there is no privacy no private
certification there's just one one
single mechanism to become a certified
Wetland scientist at that time you also
receive a license they are two two of
the same so there's no there's no
there's no separate
organization that issues simply a
certification
to
um
to practice Wetland science follow-up
follow-up so are you receiving
so you receive the certification from
the state not from the organization
that's providing the training and all
that that's correct it's not provided
it's not the certification is not
provided by our by our organization
um our organization does
work uh close closely with government
agencies to ensure that we're providing
adequate training at our seminars so
that we can as scientists each biennium
demonstrate that we have the sufficient
coursework in professional development
some of which includes
ethical ethics training two two credit
two credits
earlier there was a mention that
um maybe I misunderstood but I thought
the private organization
um could take some action against
somebody who was not following those
ethics or or other things and how does
that work I think Paul says the
president of nainers can speak better to
that but but as as a as a board we also
have a code of ethics and but there is a
mechanism to just to clarify which board
you mean
or the private organization I use the
wrong term not bored as an as um as an
association we have the ability to
to um
to recognize any instances when there
would be an unethical uh an Ethics
violation of sorts to to remove
a person or member of the association
but that is not directly tied to their
certification or
slash license
they'd be removed from membership in the
organization is what would happen
correct okay thank you okay
all right well that's very interesting
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair
so uh one of the things that clearly has
to be considered is whether the net
benefit of the the retaining the current
structure which seems to be functioning
excellently well it's a simple uh
relatively simple uh Arrangement and it
works
and we are talking about some
slightly different
process
where the license might go away
and the question is whether it's worth
the trouble of creating this new
condition situation of vis-a-vis what it
currently exists and I mean there there
are some other professions for example
nurses are called registered nurses but
that registration is still effectively a
licensed certified public accountant
that's they are basically licensed even
though though they're called certified
public accountant so what's up do you
guys have similar to our situation right
what's that that sounds very similar to
our situation here right yeah right so
that that's what we're wrestling with
whether the process that we're looking
at here is worth the trouble to try to
create a new situation and and save the
license fee or whatever
I think at the end of the day you know
it's it's important to recognize the
laws and rules that require the use of
the science are not are not going away
they'll still be there
right and
and it's
very important to recommend just to
remember that the certified well and
Sciences today really helped facilitate
that process through the permitting and
and it there's there's absolutely no
doubt about that by removing survey well
scientists it would it would have an
adverse or have the opposite effect of
what yeah you folks may be trying to
achieve the question is not removing
certified Wetland Sciences saying
whether the state should be
issuing the certificate rather than your
organization
and that's something that
um apparently the certification
requirements in statute are the same as
your Professional Organization there's
no additional requirement for the state
license
so the question is
is that how much value is added by that
I see so thank you very much I really
appreciate the information you've raised
a truly impressive number of questions
great thank you for your time yeah no
it's
and contact information okay thank you
very much we will appreciate that
because we might have more questions
for you specifically but I think it's
more for What would
what was the intention of this change in
regard to Wetland scientists you will
notice on the letter we do have a
legislative committee within manners our
organization Kimberly Pease is the chair
of that she apologizes she had family
commitments couldn't be here today but
she will be dealing with this as it
moves forward as our legislative chair
so that's home excellent take these
legislative changes okay you know I
don't don't doubt it all right and thank
you very much for your time and uh thank
you for hearing us great thank you
[Music]
and I think the questions we had
regarding stamps and licenses and so
forth is pretty much the same for
soil scientists
um
Foresters
and Landscape Architects so if you you
could
address those though
the dog if you could step up for this
so
and I'd like to comment that the
governor's talk about Wetland about
Landscape Architects needing a license
to plant a rose bush is actually
incorrect there are specific exemptions
and a lot of them and the only time you
need a license as far as I can tell is
when your customer for example the
federal government Demands a stamp
document
and that's how do they get the stamps
that's one question we have for you good
morning my name is Douglas osterhau I am
general counsel for the office of
professional licensure and certification
thank you for having me here this
morning my understanding and I'm going
to confirm this I have it written down
as an action item because I want to
confirm this with executive director
Courtney who unfortunately couldn't be
here today
um my understanding is to get away from
Individual board stamps and create one
oplc stamp that would say any of these
boards any of these certifications
licenses that need a stamp have sort of
the writ of approval if you will
um So the plan is that you're going to
develop a
a stamp
that you can
provide to any of these professions that
need one that don't also need any other
my understanding of this situation is
that right now there are individual
stamps that do exist and that's a long
term so if a stamp is in rule right now
you probably have the physical stamp in
the office I've seen them yesterday they
are long term would be remove all the
different individual stamps
streamline that get it down to one but
how that's nice to know but the real
question is how do you decide who do you
give them to
because
if you're requiring
if a wetland scientist for example is
required to have a stamp to submit plans
to
a town or even an individual landowner
how do you decide who is an appropriate
person to have such a stamp
if they're not going to be licensed or
registered or otherwise
communicating with your office that's
the whole heart of the issue as far as
I'm concerned sure so
I mean right now if if you meet the
standards whatever the standards are in
law or rule sorry representative
um
yes so yeah right right and so getting
where the licensure doesn't necessarily
mean we get rid of the certification or
the ability to identify individuals who
are certified I think one thing that so
I'm not an expert on the process for the
Wetland soils but my understanding is
that the certification is actually a
national
certification it well it's also
reflected in our statute and the license
would give you the ability to work in
the state
you are issued the license when you
receive the certification but if you
still have that certification and you
still need that stamp
I mean that's a process we we can still
have that list of people 300 identified
and I can also run this by executive
director Courtney to get and we're going
we're going to need to see that because
I've been
we do need the authority to we need
somebody to have the authority to
discipline
misbehaving Wetland scientists whether
it's their organization or or our
organization
but that's needed even if it doesn't
come up very often
and the professionals need a way that
they can identify themselves and
classically that's been a stamp which is
and so therefore they need a way to get
a stamp that says you know
Mr Adams certified Wetland scientist
that they can they can use
um and the question is does the
license it doesn't seem to have any
requirement in addition to their
professional certification which are
listed in statute
so what if the only value is that you're
providing a stamp that
um
can you help
help me understand why what the point is
of I'm not understanding the question
I'm sorry well if you're going to still
need to track who is a certified Wetland
scientist so that you can provide the
stamp that they need to have their
results accepted
um
what do you mean by eliminating the
license
it seems
it seems like you can't unless you're
going to totally do something different
representative black issue maybe you can
help him understand right
um so first of all this may have been
done due to a misunderstanding on my
part or someone else's we just heard
that the uh the private organization
that provides the training and all that
does not do certification yet you seem
to imply that they do so
that's the first thing
I've got the names of some organizations
in my folder I'm reaching for them okay
um
and and then the follow-up assuming they
do offer certification or something like
it whatever they call it
um we heard there seems to be some kind
of
you know they can have a disciplinary
process and if they're not happy with if
they think someone's misbehaved they can
you know exclude them from the
organization the question is if they're
providing a certification does that then
mean
that um that certification would be
revoked
and then the question then would be
you know how would uh
how would somebody who's going to employ
them know that's happened unless you
know I guess it'd be fraud if they said
they had certification but then but
anyway that's that's where I'm heading
I've written now that as an action item
to research that question I think we
just heard in testimony that a
professional association can take action
against a certification
but we've also heard that they don't do
certification but that may have been due
to confusion so what I appreciate my
understanding is that for professional
Wetland scientists there is the PWS
certification which is a national
certification board
that's not a certification coming from
the state
we issue the license but the
certification comes from a national
accrediting agency
okay and and follow up follow up this is
uh kind of the second part you said
maybe it's my misunderstand but you said
that all these stamps would be combined
to one I assume
you're not literally meaning that
because I assume you'd have to have a
stamp that indicated what they were the
Wetland science or soil scientists or
professional engineer whatever is that
correct or
I mean was it one Authority that would
Grant these stamps or you really mean
one stamp that's the same
other than someone's name I guess
yeah
I think again this is if you don't know
you'll come back well my understanding
is that it's essentially that one stamp
would mean you met the criteria that
would have gotten you the other stamp
but it just but what criteria that's
because there's different criteria for
different professions right yeah you'd
have to have a one one for
soil scientists a wetland scientists and
Landscape Architects well those would be
established in law would be established
in Rule and all the one stamp would say
is that you met whatever those standards
established in law and Rule would be and
again this is something that we need to
we need more information for deciding
this because
we
in the search for simplifying the state
government we do not want to get these
people out of
unable to work because we as we need
them
um
I and I think that the other uh
technical professions soil scientists
and probably Professional Engineers and
Architects are the same way that the
requirements in statute are basically
meet your professional organizations
requirements
and then and then deal with the state
it certainly looks that way for
Professional Engineers
I hope hope we can meet again and have
director Courtney here who might well
we'd also like to see the exact wording
of what how they're what's happening and
that is unfortunately unavailable
okay representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so uh
one of the problems I have I I wish I
alluded to a little bit earlier is
whether we we're going to disrupt this
currently functioning situation
um whether the you know the
pain that is going to be caused to some
degree is worth the benefit of getting
because to me it seems like there are
three stages of of
involvement if you will one is the
lowest level is registration where you
just come in and you say I'm X
no examination is involved no high level
of in some cases no high level of
training is involved but uh you know you
want to have a handle on these people
and we had this a couple of years ago
when uh when we had the case at Exeter
Hospital of this individual who came in
from out of state
he was a medical technician okay turns
out he was diverting drugs
his own use he wound up infecting and
ultimately killing several people many
more were infected
so we wanted to register these people
because otherwise it was kind of like
the state was had a gigantic kick me
sign on it
um that meant these people could come in
and nobody was tracking him nobody was
registering them nobody had any ideas so
we created a registration for a certain
group of people who were handling drugs
the janitors and so forth they were
exempting they weren't involved
next higher level is certification which
says you had this training you've
demonstrated competence you have the
certifications which says you know how
to do this that's what it was
the next higher level is you have the
certification already but the license
says you can legally do it in the state
of New Hampshire and the benefit of the
license is that it gives you the
oversight and the control of the
practitioners because if somebody is out
of line either because they
they're technically you know incapable
incapable or incompetent or they're
they're morally moral turpitude which
has its own uh negative aspects in terms
of that categorization but also somebody
who was maybe has drug issues
or alcohol issues in other words they
they have all the skills and so forth so
they've got this other problem you know
uh they're they're criminal in in some
other respects or not suitable in other
respects and and so forth but the idea
with certification is once somebody can
do something and they have a certificate
says that they can do it you can't
really you can take the certification
away but they still know how to do it
right they still know all these things
and now you've taken away the thing that
says that they know how to do it that's
a kind of a how many angels on the head
of a pin in the way yes representative
the question becomes how do we deal with
this situation do you gentlemen where
you don't seem to have many problems
with people
um and so the certification is kind of
all you really need the license doesn't
really add anything
because you don't need control or
oversight Maybe
but we're still tinkering with an
existing structure who knows and and I
think we still have
I know some steps to go to make sure
that we oh get getting it we absolutely
need to find whether it's worth the
trouble we're talking about Crossing and
also whether it's it's worth the trouble
for them to get the license but and
that's going to depend on the details
that we don't have
all right
um
and I noticed that the
there don't appear to be any people on
this list that are medical
that are medical licenses that will be
practicing individually which is the one
of the points we have is that it for
most medical professions you cannot
independently Bill Insurance especially
Medicaid
for your services unless you have a
license and that but these people
are are primarily non-medical and the
medical licenses are people that are
going to be working for somebody else
so that the
okay so that then I if we're going to
talk about that particular aspect uh it
seems to me like there are some people
on uh the the list
that uh where it's a medical profession
where the safe health and safety of the
of the public is potentially in play
for example limited x-ray machine
operator licensed nursing assistant
um the the
but again those are people that are will
be working for
for doctors for hospitals for clinics
and the doctor the hospital or the
clinic is licensed and is responsible
for the
way their their employees work
I I've heard that you know at that
aspect how about in in number eight in
repeal boards Medical Imaging and
radiation therapist Advisory Board this
is something where uh the it does
involve the health and safety of the of
the we haven't gotten to the boards
we're just talking about the individual
licenses okay well and and I and
the these I mean you're not going to
have some someone who's a radio a uh
a limited x-ray machine operator opening
their x-rays R Us shop on Main Street
which is what they need which is what is
needed for a specific
um what you need a license for I I agree
with you it doesn't seem likely but the
thing is there are lots of unresolved
issues that that fit in here and so
okay and I can see that you I can see
that you are laboring with uh the
complexity and the totality of this
issue in which there are multiple I yeah
I understand it's like the Tower of
blocks you can pull out this one but you
can't pull out that one the
um I understand from
other sources that the oplc section of
House Bill 2 is 300 pages
and
so
yes so so this one we've got the
question of assuming that you know fine
you don't have the license how do you
the question is how are they going to
deal with the question of providing
stamps and discipline even though
discipline for
Wetland scientists soil scientists and
so forth is rare I'm sure it still
happens
we have data that shows how rare but
still does not somebody's got to do it
and how and how do we make sure that it
when it is needed it happens
so
I don't think we can specifically say
we're we're in support of the of of
those professions licenses being
repealed unless we know how these
particular issues are being settled
okay
all right gold that's
any other useful information no thank
you you're just getting the action items
all right uh going on to some of the
other issues
um Universal license recognition
I believe we've included that in the
separate bill I think it was
um
I don't remember
we had a bill that dealt with that we
passed it
and I think we want to
um
let's get the number for that one
all right the clear lines between the
fact finding and adjudicive hearings the
investatory hearings process and all
that
that is something that we are working on
in House Bill 655 and I'd rather warrant
in house bill 2. because
you you run the possibility of changing
one
of synchronizing the two facts that
needs to be in 655 and the subcommittee
is has at least one more meeting on that
so I I think we want to say that take we
don't want that
if I could comment on that I yeah I mean
I don't know what these two or three
hundred pages are going to be but I mean
if it completely rewrites all of the
licensing there may be problems with
references in 655 that point to things
that don't exist
so
or any other Bill we've in any other
Bill yes it's going to be yes it's going
to be a challenge for everybody to keep
track of who's doing what to whom and I
would like to make sure that we do as
much as we can to eliminate duplication
representative Schmidt okay well I I
have one other problem a problem with
this whole situation in which you I
think slightly alluded to and that is
the idea that this is being put in House
Bill too uh yeah I I think this is a an
issue which deserves to be stand or fall
on its own because putting it in the
budget
you know it it gives it uh it it burdens
the budget process and the budget itself
with uh an element of risk or
uncertainty and so forth which the
budget doesn't need it's got enough
problems on its own and enough gravity
on its own that it should stand and fall
on its own uh and putting and and
putting this thing in there just adds an
element of of of of risk as I say that I
think is uh is unwise we we should it
this issue should be dealt with
separately
major reorganizations
generally appear in the budget because
they don't actually happen unless the
governor approves of them
and is willing to push them so
I would agree with you I uh
somewhat in that since we already have a
bill
655 that reorganizes oplc fairly
exhaustively we want to make sure
there's nothing in House Bill 2 that
duplicates it
um so looking at these over this
overview there all the
going down to uh the last two bullets
most of the rest of that ought to be in
655 rather than house built it
I'm I agree with you we don't want to
put the
um
we don't want to burden the budget with
the this reorganization that we're
already dealing with in a different Bill
and having
two different bills we'd have to keep
track of and and know which one takes
precedence is a major effort that
that I don't want to have to do
um
but I think most of these issues
until you get to the licenses and so
forth
the last two bullets are already in 655
and are already being dealt with and our
recommendation to finances take them out
of house bill too
wouldn't you agree
I definitely would it I agree that that
putting this in the budget I think is
just
saying you know
that you're you're saying can you do
this and and also juggle the uh 15 balls
at the same time and you're going like
why would you want to try to do both
simultaneously it's just there's no
benefit to it that I can see
and there's plenty of risk okay
um
the
the moving the move to oplc from the
Secretary of State's office
and the board of Licensing for
interpreters for the deaf deaf blind and
hard of hearing
um
those are all
let's see the board of auctioneers and
the interpreters for deaf deafblind and
so forth we we deal with the structure
of those boards they're fairly similar
to
what we have for the other professional
boards
and
I don't see why they you know just
moving them can't be done in House Bill
too that's a fairly normal thing to
happen
um
you just want to make sure that there's
the something like the existing licenses
will will be continue the existing rules
will continue
because you don't want to disrupt the
auctioneers or the interpreters either
way you want to have carry the
regulatory structure along with them
um
boxing and wrestling is not actually a
professional board the license I believe
referees for things like these days it's
mostly mixed martial arts
and it's
um
we've occasionally had a dealing about
it but it's not a professional board by
any means
and I don't know anything about the
professional bondsman
does anybody
okay seeing none will
I don't
all right let's
we don't know anything about those guys
the auctioneers and and deaf
interpreters
I don't see any reason why they can't be
moved and
with with with
reasonable accuracy
and uh
okay
does
all right
the advisor the changes to advisory
boards
we did some of that last session
and
it all depends on how you do it it's not
as simple as it looks
um
I'm not sure how we would what we could
say about that
um
does anybody have any ideas of what we
could do about
converting those to
the the intent to make those advisory
boards representative like us and the
one I have some familiarity with is
working with the acupuncturists in the
past is uh I think this could work I
don't see a problem with it for them the
other is I don't know that much about
yeah I know the uh
oh which one
the nursing home administrators is
again it's a small number of their
professionals I think there's only a
couple hundred of them right and I think
one of the uh
the director Courtney has said in the
past one of the problems with the ones
that have very few I think the one that
was talking about the time was the
Midwife free council is if they actually
have authority as opposed to be an
advisory that can pose a
Federal Anti-Trust issue and that I
think one of the Carolinas actually lost
a case related to that recently yeah
okay well that's
all right
but it but again we can't really say go
for it until we see the details because
it's been
um
even even if we agree with the concept
well I I think that's true for all you
need to look over again the same with
the merged boards we need to see the
details before we we uh
before we say go ahead or don't go ahead
right and there may be
um
issues that I mean hopefully been
considered but may not have like maybe
the stamp issue was considered maybe not
I don't know and who knows what else
there might be in some of these well
they're combining the land surveyors
with the Professional Engineers
and I don't see why they shouldn't also
if we need to include the boards for
Landscape Architects Wetland scientists
and natural scientists because all those
professional groups are very similar in
that you get the the Technical Training
and then you apply for the license and
get a stamp and the amount of disa
disciplinary issues that come up is very
low
um
so
one Tech One Professional board rather
than uh
four or five of them it might make
things a little easier
right we need to look at at the details
I mean the question is is the dis
investigation disciplinary going to be
handled by the certification
organizations or by oplc or I don't know
what the plan is yep definitely need the
details to do anything on those
um
so
all right well I'm
and all the rest of them you know we
gotta we've got to look at the details
um
so
I don't is there anybody that has
something that it'd be useful to talk
about
I have another action item for old PLC
though
uh when do the licenses that are
repealed going to expire
and are you going to be issuing refunds
if they are
if they retire if they expire before the
two-year period or whatever it is
I mean somebody who apply who gets a
license the week before you uh repeal
the need for it is going to feel very
silly
yeah
representative McGuire you have a
comment
so representative Dan Maguire
representing Epsom I'm on the house
finance committee division one which is
this area that we're you know almost
anything from Edna will go to my
division if it's related to finance
I just wanted to step back and take a
look at the big picture of why we're
sitting here today talking about these
things and it has to do with
the overall budget process
the governor is someone who's clearly
involved in the legislative process more
important than any single legislator or
or body in the sense that he has the
veto over anything we do right so so
he's he's effectively the most important
legislator in that sense
but
the governors
bill so so that's that's a negative
that's not a positive but but via the
budget process we have handed to the
governor a positive which is the
governor creates the first draft of
House Bill 1 and House Bill 2. House
Bill 2 is General legislation and so
this is the one time per year per
session that the governor gets to write
legislation right and create it and I
don't think that this organization of
the budget process is const is specified
in the Constitution it's effectively an
extra power that we've given by setting
up the process this way and it doesn't
necessarily have to be that way right I
mean the the agencies it could come
straight to the finance committee and
write the budget that way and the
governor could be not involved in the
budget process for example so
so I think that's something that this
committee might think about whether
putting this sort of General legislative
creation power in the governor's hands
is appropriate I mean it it's
um
you know it's it's easy to see why he
wants to do it and especially in this
case because our state is hurting for
employees right I mean the the real
reason this all this stuff is in
legislation is because of the general
lack of employees in the state right and
so one of those has to do with licensing
is a is a barrier to employment and so
the governor obviously and we all have
an incentive to reduce those employment
barriers so it's this is well the
motivation is there but I'm not sure the
way the process is going
um makes sense I think yes thank you I
agree and that's why I say that we've
already got the re restructuring of the
oplc and many of these issues in a
separate bill
created by the legislature which is 655
and we would recommend those not be in
the budget
because
they're not needed there
and and also it's we're already working
on it you know glad to know the governor
supports the idea we're expecting his
signature
but uh
it shouldn't be in the budget
so I guess what I'm thinking is it
wouldn't necessarily be a tragedy if all
this kind of stuff became a bill next
year and was not part of the budget
right I mean it
if if it's too complicated right I mean
if all these things look very reasonable
and we should go ahead with it and the
sooner the better right the sooner we
can reduce barriers to employment
obviously the better but if it's super
complicated and there's a lot of details
in every little piece
maybe it's better as a bill next year
rather than a budget this year Well
having seen many of these
uh items before
I mean this there's a lot in here that
we've seen seen already
then the
we've already identified issues with the
technical boards that have to be solved
before we go any further
the booth license is already in another
bill that we're dealing with in
committee
uh athlete agents
we've tried to delete several times and
have not been able to pass
um same with Hawkers and Peddlers and
itinerant vendors we've repealed those
last session while we didn't repeal them
we tried to pass the house failed in the
Senate
um
the medical technicians
again we've tried to repeal that license
but failed
um
so
I don't think it's as
unless the government
I don't think these are as simple
as the governor seems to think I mean he
certainly mistaken the
um
Landscape Architects
and mischaracterize what the license is
needed for
because we've already Exempted plant you
know gardeners landscapers Etc you're
only needed for making plans when the
customer Demands a stamp
which is
basically federally funded Highway
projects and possibly if they're redoing
the the
they have a they have a grading problem
at the prison in Berlin
other than that you don't need a license
so
representative blackis yep couple things
one is
um
I mean we're kind of
at Sea here because we don't have
details and
questions do you have any idea when we
might see the actual language because if
a lot of it is very similar to the 655
that's great and then we can look at the
other separate pieces
and that might not be a huge deal
however if it's being done very
differently than 655
that's a different challenge I mean I I
do in principle I think support what the
governor is trying to do and we do in my
view have an issue in New Hampshire that
we license a lot more professions than
almost any other state in the Union
which I see is a bad thing
but the question is how to go about
doing this
I think we're expecting house bill to
the end of this week that's what I've
heard so it's certainly not out already
yeah well it's um we'll have we'll have
to look at it because in most of these
cases it depends on how it's implemented
I mean I had a bill to delete the
licensing for medical technicians which
is which is purely a registration no
skill required no nothing just you know
give us your name and address and pay
the feed you've got a certificate and
you've got a registration
because they're employers to take care
of most of the work of of determining
who's qualified and and and discipline
or they should
but
again that
that was fought in the house on the
basis of one incident 10 years ago
and it and lost on the basis of one
bad actor and I certainly can't give any
anybody any Assurance there won't ever
be another bad actor
but uh
but in the athlete agents was you know
recommended to be the sponsor of the
bill repealing the need for the
registration
recommended
killing the bill was it three years ago
four years ago something like that
he came in with the repeal we don't need
this and then he said well after a
couple of hearings and talking about it
what does we don't know what the um
professional organizations are doing
and they were changing their rules at
the time
so
thank you well there are several aspects
to uh that I want to discuss at this
point number one is I think that the the
the process has one
pretty important flaw and that is where
the rest of us
it's supposed to be a full committee
work session but unfortunately most of
the people are either out of town or on
vacation so that's kind of like having a
football team football game where you
only have three of the players on one of
the teams yes representative
and it was more important that we start
in on this and look for some of the
zingers like the stamps I'm not
criticizing you madam chair I really am
not because you're trying to deal with
the
the issues that come before this
Committee in a way but but the net
effect that in nevertheless is that we
are missing people who are all going to
have to vote either yay or nay
um so uh that is a fact that we need to
be cognizant of then one of the things
that representative Dan McGuire was
talking about is how we are suffering in
New Hampshire from a dearth of workers
in all across the board
that is true are we unique among states
in this in this in this aspect and I
suggest that we are not this is a uni
kind of a general malaise that that we
are facing in the country because uh
uh we well I don't have to go into it
we're all aware of it
um but it is a reality so that to the
way that we are trying to fix something
in New Hampshire that is is not is not
unique to New Hampshire we're kidding
ourselves if we think we're going to
attract all the missing workers here
um as opposed to any other state
especially when we have weather like
this
um but anyway I'm here too uh so but
another aspect is to the the degree we
put it in the budget even though it's a
good vehicle
um in some respects it also is a a
political instrument with regard to
aspects that that are going to
potentially uh sink the budget
we don't know that yet because we
haven't seen it
um so uh and and then the other aspect
is that anything having to do with the
health and safety of the citizens of New
Hampshire
um
uh and a number of these do uh is
problematical and needs to be deal dealt
with separately in my view so I'm
willing to continue but but we are
missing some of the key players in that
regard as well director Courtney is with
all due respect to Mr ostrad uh is uh is
a key player here
um and there are also some other people
who are not here so yes no the
this was intended essentially as triage
to say we don't need to worry too much
about this section or in the case of the
principles we don't want those in the
budget we're dealing with them in 655
right that's
right but the
deletion of the licenses
and moving the boards to PLC well that's
something
that that's in-house Bill too that is
generally done reasonably well with the
moving pieces of state government around
that's commonly in the budget and I'm
not and I don't think it's
as long as you take the regulatory
structure with you I don't think it's an
issue
that you know the rules the requirements
for the licenses
and so forth and that ought to be and if
that's in not in house bill to along
with the movement we better make sure
that that happens
um the deletion of the licenses and the
combination of the boards we can't
discuss very much until we know the
details and I'm very disappointed we
don't have the details the only
Advantage putting them in House Bill 2
has from my point of view
is that they've got an extra two weeks
to work on it House Bill 655 has to be
out of committee by mid-march
and so we're we're working on it we've
made a lot of progress but
it may or may not be ready to be exact
next week it may have to go go out
another week
um
that's but that's our deadline we don't
have we only have
we only have two weeks the budget has
another two weeks after that so
um
we'll have to see what comes out in
House Bill 2 and how PLC answers the
questions we've asked before we do
anything other than suggest that the
Rhys
the initial restructuring for oplc the
investigatory stuff belongs in 655 and
not in house bill 2.
which will probably take at least five
or six pages away from oplc from from
house bill to
anybody else have any comments or
anything useful we can do
all right yes and I can imagine we will
have some more full committee work
sessions with more people involved it's
uh
all right
so thank you all for coming and thank
you for sharing your expertise and and
and thank you for FL for pointing out
some of the issues that we we need to
deal with
all right
excellent timing representative Bailey I
am impressed
foreign